[Music]
on this wednesday night the fight to
control ferocious fires in bc
the military moving in to help and the
weather making conditions even more
volatile this is a graphic reminder of
how
climate change is with us why canada's
fire seasons are only getting
worse central china
submerged raging flood waters inundate
cities
after the heaviest rainfall on record
plus
negotiations over westjet and the
federal government and talks about a
relief package
what it means for some frustrated
customers and
game on the women of team canada take to
the field
in tokyo
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight in british columbia
where a growing number of communities
are
on edge and under threat from
fast-moving wildfires
more than three thousand properties are
under evacuation order right now
another sixteen thousand are on alert
people have been told to be ready to
flee at a moment's notice
and it's not just one part of the
province that's affected
normally in a fire season we're not
hopping in every corner of the province
this is the situation right now we're
almost hopping in every corner and with
the weather predictions as they are
we have some challenges ahead
the immediate forecast calls for several
more days of hot
dry windy weather bad news for fire
crews already dealing with volatile
conditions
teams from new brunswick and mexico are
headed to bc to help
and the federal government is deploying
hundreds of members of the canadian
military
here's what they'll be dealing with
there are now nearly 300 active fires
burning across
bc 95 are out of control
one of the most concerning is the one
burning near oliver and
soyuz in bc's wine country global's paul
johnson is
in usoyus tonight tracking that fire for
us
paul give us a sense of what it's like
donna the incame
fire is burning on this mountainside
right next to the heart of bc
wine country the blazes are basically
scattered in a 30 kilometer long
strip from a soyuz here in the south to
oliver up in the north
now check out this video this was the
scene
of that mountainside from a soyuz
tuesday night when we arrived
some people in the soyuz were literally
going out into their driveways
and front yards with lawn chairs to
watch that fire
wondering what would happen so far a
couple of hundred properties have been
ordered to evacuate
hundreds more are on evacuation alert
including some
on the outskirts of the town of oliver
now all of this is happening of course
right at the peak of the summer tourist
season so
many of the evacuees are vacationers who
had to leave
campgrounds some of them have been
making the best of it they've relocated
to parking lots into soyuz we spoke to
some of them
here's how they described their
experience when the fires were happening
we didn't like what we saw on monday
night our neighbors at the campsite
we made a decision to get out so we
trailered our boats
hooked up everything got the got the rvs
all hooked up and
packed up and we got out after midnight
on monday
we're watching we're hoping that
everything's going to be okay
but like i said yesterday when that wind
changes the fire could be right back
here
so you might be able to hear that
chopper in the background for about the
past
hour or so it's been working the fire
skimming water
from lake and soyuz and then dropping it
on some of the hot spots
the continuing problem here not just at
this fire but throughout
southern british columbia has been
really challenging
weather conditions this morning it was
very windy
in a soyuz but the big problem is these
persistent
dry conditions and the forecast which is
offering
no meaningful rain on the horizon
donna all right paul johnson in soyuz bc
thanks
the military is also deploying to
manitoba to help battle fires in that
province
the federal government says up to 120
specially trained personnel will be sent
to build fire lines and extinguish hot
spots
nearly 140 active wildfires are burning
across
manitoba the fire situation also remains
severe in northwestern ontario
yesterday 81 new forest fires were
confirmed
many were sparked by lightning several
first nations in the area have been
evacuated
what is happening from ontario to bc is
another reminder of the impact climate
change is having
on how and where we live scientists warn
it will only get worse
eric sorenson reports on the fire
dangers in the years ahead and
what can be done to mitigate the risks
canada has a quarter of the world's
boreal forests a storehouse of potential
fuel for wildfires
it means canadians are among the most
vulnerable to a climate that is warming
british columbia has only declared four
states of emergency in its history of
fighting wildfires
but three have come in the last five
fire seasons this is a graphic reminder
of how climate change is with us not
just
intermittently but all the time 2017 was
one of the worst years in bc
more than a million hectares burned 65
000 people were evacuated from their
homes
2018 another province-wide state of
emergency
fires that cost 650 million dollars to
suppress
and 2021 saw the town of lytton
incinerated
again residents fled increased
evacuations
a sign of the times it used to maybe be
fairly rare
and but now it's every year there are
many
right now there's thousands of people
out of their homes in bc there have been
over 1100 wildfires in 2021
more than for the entire fire seasons
the previous two years
in all 300 000 hectares have burned so
far three times the average for this
time of year
we're ending up with larger fires that
are more intense
the amount of hectares that burn each
year has doubled
since the 1970s and that increasing
trend of the area burned is focused in
western canada
and in the north british columbia
declared its first state of emergency
for wildfires in 2003 when the okanagan
was ravaged by fire
200 homes in kelowna were destroyed and
since then
communities have only become bigger bc's
population has grown by a million people
more are living in or near forests an
expanding wildland urban
interface will bring greater risks and
costs for british
seeing more columbians in flammable
landscapes
if we just keep doing what we're doing
suppression resources are already
overwhelmed
and with climate change more people
living out in burnable areas
it's only going to get worse experts say
canada is a flammable country
built to burn with population sprawl and
climate change intersecting in our
forest landscape
canadians will need new strategies to
learn to live with fire erik sorensen
global news
toronto extreme weather has also hit
central
china record-setting rainfall there
caused devastating flooding displacing
more than a million people
as it pulled into the station people
were trapped inside
two subway cars in shenzhou terrified
passengers watched through a window as
water ripped through the tunnel
they spent at least 20 minutes stranded
in chest high
muddy water before they were rescued at
least 12 people
didn't make it thousands of emergency
personnel have been deployed to help
rescue those stranded
and people are banding together to try
to save each other
the torrent of rain turned roads into
rapidly flowing rivers
this woman became stuck while riding her
scooter people tried to use a rope to
get her to safety
but she lost her grip
she managed to grab a door handle and
desperately tried to hang on but the
water
was too powerful
she was swept away until two men jumped
into the water and were able to save her
motorists formed human chains as they
struggled to get off the road
from saturday to tuesday more than 617
millimeters of rain fell in the central
chinese city
that's nearly as much as its yearly
average
several major rivers burst their banks
and the flooding extended to about a
dozen cities
more than 100 000 people have been
relocated to safe zones
the rain has started to ease but much of
the region china's bread basket
remains underwater extreme rainfall like
this is becoming more common because of
climate change
and it's exacerbated by widespread dam
building
in china
in iran people are taking to the streets
angry with the government
and a severe water shortage this is the
sixth straight night demonstrations have
been held
across the country at least three people
including a police officer have been
killed in the unrest
human rights groups say nearly 5 million
iranians lack
access to clean drinking water right now
the country has been facing a prolonged
drought and rising temperatures from
climate change and critics say
the government's mismanagement of
natural resources has worsened
the water crisis
back in this country plans are underway
to search the site of a former
residential school in brantford ontario
to determine if
unmarked graves exist there and
survivors of the former mohawk institute
residential school say
it should be a criminal investigation
plans for the search will be announced
soon and survivors want all evidence
preserved and protected fifteen thousand
students attended the school
many are unaccounted for
what we know is that the trc discovered
records of at least 54 death records in
the 142 years
associated with the school what we don't
know
is where those little bodies are buried
the mohawk institute opened in 1828 it
burned down
twice and relocated before closing in
1970.
it was one of the longest running
residential schools in canada
a national summit on anti-semitism took
place in ottawa today
government officials and jewish leaders
from across the country took
part but who was left off the invite
list
caused some consternation opposition
leaders were not invited to participate
only to listen including green party
leader anime paul the only
federal leader who is jewish i am the
first jewish woman to lead
a major federal party in canada and i'm
only the second jewish person
in the last 45 years so my perspective
matters in this conversation i am part
of the jewish community
to have it excluded is again i believe a
loss for us all
among those who did get to speak were
prime minister justin trudeau
and former justice minister irwin kotler
now canada's special envoy
for preserving holocaust remembrance and
combating anti-semitism
he proposed a 10-point plan for canada
to follow
that anti-semitism cannot be fought nor
can it be won by jews acting alone
what is needed is a constituency
of conscience and action no canadian
should ever fear
to practice their religion of course
good intentions are not enough
we've seen the rise recently
anti-semitism
but it wasn't zero before
national discussions on fighting racism
and hatred are far
from over a summit on combating the rise
of islamophobia in canada will be held
tomorrow no cross-border road trips for
canadians just yet
coming up the u.s holds off on returning
the favor for
fully vaccinated visitors and the
turbulence for air travelers as westjet
opts out of federal aid
the u.s has extended non-essential
travel restrictions at the land border
until at least
august 21st the department of homeland
security says the threat of covid19
transmission remains too high to ease
measures
canada will allow fully vaccinated
americans to travel into this country
starting august 9th a canadian citizen
can fly
into the united states if they're fully
vaccinated why can't they drive
uh you know the the immunity is is not
diminished
because you're in a car this is this is
ridiculous
fully vaccinated travelers from other
countries will be allowed to enter
canada as of
september 7th months of negotiations
between westjet and the federal
government have
ended and the airline has turned down a
federal aid package
other canadian airlines have accepted
the federal lifeline including air
canada
and gaviola explains why westjet is
going it alone
and what it means for customers
an airline recovery has begun across
canada fully vaccinated tourists from
the us will be able to start visiting in
early august
so westjet plans to continue ramping up
its services
moving beyond the need for a government
bailout a statement by the westjet group
says given encouraging vaccination rates
across the country
both parties have mutually agreed to
shift focus from these negotiations
and away from taxpayer-funded support to
leading the safe restart of the travel
and tourism sector
it's owned by george schwartz one of
canada's most successful business people
it's privately owned
and they don't want to share financial
data with the public or indeed with the
government
schwartz is the founder chairman and ceo
of onyx corporation which owns westjet
privately
unlike publicly traded companies air
canada and transat at which cut deals
with the federal government
that support came with strings attached
limiting executive compensation
the air canada deal included a 500
million dollar equity stake
a long list of potential sticking points
and negotiations with westjet
we've been loyal to westjet for so many
years we've always flown with them
and that this is the way we're being
treated because because they want to
keep our money
it makes me angry that means westjet
customers who've been issued travel
vouchers instead of refunds
are out of luck that for us was
extremely frustrating
i was going on that leave so you know
reduce pay
so we could use that money the canadian
transportation agency has received more
than 3 200 pandemic related complaints
about westjet
ottawa isn't confirming how many federal
dollars westjet has already received but
in a statement to global news it says
support for airlines totals more than 2
billion in wage subsidies
plus 1 billion announced in the fall
economic statement for airports and
smaller airlines
analysts say barring another negative
turn of events the worst of the
turbulence is behind the industry
ann gaviola global news toronto
still ahead we hear from a former
interpreter for canadian troops who says
he's being
hunted by the taliban
translators who worked side by side with
canadian soldiers in afghanistan keep
pleading for help because they worked
with foreign forces they're considered
traitors by some in their country and
live in fear of being attacked or killed
by the taliban
the federal government knows lives are
hanging in the balance
mike armstrong reached one man who says
the taliban are searching
for him the afghan military has been
losing ground
for weeks when it does the taliban moves
in
as they do they have targets yeah i was
in a
bad place we spoke to a former afghan
interpreter who worked with canadian
troops
in 2010 and 2011. last week he was in a
town
outside kandahar where protecting his
identity he says the taliban was
after him they already have information
about the people who work with the
coalition forces or
metal when they enter to the city
they were going directly to the house
home and take out him from the home
and they kill in front of their parents
of their family now that interpreter's
been moved with his wife and daughter
where exactly we've been asked not to
say
only that it's a safer place and a
location that'll make it easier to get
them out of the country eventually
but that family is one of close to two
dozen being helped by a group of retired
canadian
soldiers they've been organizing
fundraising and calling in favors
to help people who used to work with
them we are not going to quit
retired corporal robin rickards is part
of the network he says he's been living
on three hours of sleep for days
and he's lost track of how many people
have jumped in with support
there's lots of people pitching in where
they uh where they can and doing what
they
what they're able to now there is
frustration with the federal government
while ottawa has said it's working on a
plan that's about all it said
there's no word on who'd qualify and
there's no timeline
these are people who believed in canada
one voice speaking out on the issue is
catherine rusk
she is the sister of captain nicola
goddard canada's first female soldier to
be killed in combat
rusk says her sister's interpreter is
still in afghanistan
i don't think canadians are okay with it
i don't think canadians are okay with
leaving
the people who have helped us behind now
a potential
airlift would likely be out of kabul but
there was a sign this week the capital
is getting less and less
safe these were rockets
landing near the presidential palace
during prayers tuesday
with each day that passes there is an
increasing urgency
to get interpreters out mike armstrong
global news
next the women to watch as canada
competes in an olympics
like no other
it's official brisbane australia will
host the 2032
summer olympic games it is the first
city to win a summer bid
under a new selection process the ioc
overhauled the process in 2019 to
discourage
cities from competing against each other
in expensive bidding wars
and competition is underway at the tokyo
games team canada is starting on the
right foot
our softball team clinched a shutout win
in their opening round
led by a pitcher who three years ago
wasn't sure she'd live to see these
games
crystal gomencing reports health
concerns have plagued the tokyo
2020 games but sarah gronawagen proved
she is in top form clinching a shutout
victory in the team's tournament debut
after battling back from a near-death
experience
with legionnaires disease the win all
the sweeter as
softball just returned to the games for
the first time in
13 years we've got a wonderful mix of
youth and experience a great chemistry
our championship culture women who are
highly committed to their craft
and we're going to win a gold medal
whether that happens or not remains to
be seen but that's our intention
canadian women are also once again
leaving their mark on the pitch
the women's soccer team is striving to
meddle in its third
consecutive olympics six minutes in
christine sinclair put canada on the
board this was her 187th goal in
international competition
then came a heart-stopping moment
canada's keeper edmonton's
stephanie lebaye clearly in pain
but unwilling to leave the match her
dedication
and skill shone through there were no
fans in the stadium but odds are
any canadian watching let out a cheer
with that save
le bay did ultimately leave the match
and japan would later tie it up
for a 1-1 draw the sapporo dome was also
the site
of the first political statements of the
games soccer players from team great
britain new zealand and
others took a knee before their matches
players
had been told such symbolic gestures
would be prohibited at these games
but when asked the ioc president
softened that stance
it is allowed it's no violation of the
rule 50. this is
expressively what has been mentioned in
these guidelines
thomas bach also found himself defending
covet 19
protocols and protections there are now
more than
75 covet 19 infections among athletes
and accredited games personnel
tokyo recorded its highest daily case
count in
six months with more than eighteen
hundred new infections
a reminder of the unrelenting realities
of this pandemic
and the backdrop of the most unusual
olympics
crystal gomencing global news london
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
air canada
is the victorian row houses known as
jelly bean row in st
john's newfoundland and labrador thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye